i'm going to talk about one of the most
famous conquerors in all of human
history and that is alexander the great
but before talking about all of the
things that he conquered let's think
about how he got started out and in
particular how he's able to consolidate
control over the empire that his father
begins
so in the last video we saw that exiting
the peloponnesian war the greeks were
weak sparta and its allies the pelp and
asian league they had won but the the
greeks were ripe for being conquered and
they end up being conquered by philip ii
king of macedonia and he rules from
pella and shortly after he becomes king
his son his first son alexander is born
and alexander is the son that philip has
with olympus olympias is the is the
daughter of the king of malosia which
makes her malosian and not macedonian
which is going to be somewhat important
later on when philip ii dies but the
early part of alexander's life is quite
good and he seems to be in favor with
his father philip ii after all alexander
seems like a decent heir to the throne
early in his life he gets from his
father what is arguably the best tutor
for sure of the time probably the best
tutor in human history in aristotle and
the way that his father convinces to
convinces him to tutor alexander when
alexander's
13 and he tutors him from when alexander
is about 13 to about 16
is
philip destroys aristotle's village of
stagira as he as he conquers greece and
aristotle says okay sure i'll
i'll tutor your son uh but in in
exchange for that why don't you rebuild
my hometown and free all of the people
who had been enslaved after the town was
conquered and so philip agrees alexander
gets a great tutor there's also the
stories of of how alexander carried
favor with his father by taming the
famous horse bucephalus who alexander
will eventually ride into asia as he
conquers the persian empire and and
beyond and philip very proud of his
young son being able to conquer this
seemingly untameable horse
as philip conquers as he conquers greece
alexander is alongside him leading
troops showing him to be a capable
military general a capable leader so all
seems to be working out well for
alexander until philip takes uh
his what ends up being his seventh and
last wife until then olympius was his
favored wife and olympias is a bit of a
character at least from the point of
historians you should take all of this
with a grain of salt because many of
these histories and these stories were
written hundreds of years later and so
it's not clear how much was a true
account versus how much was made up
but beyond olympia's not being
macedonian she is from malosia she is
also according to plutarch part of the
cult of dionysus and she worships snakes
and potentially even sleeps with snakes
which is really off-putting to a lot of
the macedonians and so
when king philip in three around 337 or
338 finds a macedonian to marry and her
name is cleopatra not the famous
cleopatra from history we'll talk about
her a few in a few hundred years
but you see here philip ii he takes his
seventh wife i don't list them all here
i only list olympias here who he marries
in 357 bce and then they have
alexander born alexander iii shortly
thereafter the next year they also have
another daughter cleopatra once again
not the cleopatra when people refer to
it in history
but then around 337 or 338 bce
he takes his seventh wife
and this seventh wife is also named
cleopatra she is macedonian philip
renames her urid eurydice after his
after his mother
and so you can imagine this is already a
little bit threatening because well what
if this cleopatra has a son and he she
eventually does have a son and now that
son would be pure macedonian as opposed
to alexander who is only half macedonian
and this becomes quite pointed at the
wedding of philip and cleopatra the
macedonian cleopatra in 337 or 338 bce
when we have this account and once again
take all of this with a grain of salt
this is an account by plutarch that was
written 400 years later
but plutarch writes at the wedding of
cleopatra this is cleopatra eurydice
this is the macedonian cleopatra the
young one whom philip fell in love with
and married she being much too young for
him her uncle atlas and you see him
on our little family tree here this is
cleopatra's uncle atlas a macedonian
her uncle
atlas in his drink desired the
macedonians would implore the gods to
give them a lawful successor to the
kingdom by his knees let me underline
that give them a lawful successor to the
kingdom you might be saying wait i
thought alexander was a lawful successor
alexander's probably thinking the same
thing
this so irritated alexander that
throwing one of the cups at his head
throwing it at at atlas's head you
villain he said what am i then a bastard
then philip alexander's dad taking atlas
part so he didn't take his son's side
he'd take the side of his in-laws rose
up and would have run his son through
but by good fortune for them both either
his over hasty rage or the wine he had
drunk made his foot slip so that he fell
down on the floor at which alexander
reproachfully insulted over him see
there said he the man who makes
preparations to pass out of europe into
asia overturned in passing from one seat
to another so if this account by
plutarch is even vaguely true it shows
this real tension that is forming
between alexander and his father and
it's of course being goaded on or likely
to be goaded on by his mother olympias
who was the primary wife for a little
bit but now she's being pushed aside in
favor of this macedonian cleopatra and
so she actually goes into voluntary
exile
alexander follows her and so things are
quite tense and they really
come to a boiling point or i guess
everything gets released a year or two
later when olympia's other child
cleopatra the other cleopatra not
cleopatra
and not the famous cleopatra from
history she gets married to olympia's
brother and so she's marrying her uncle
and many strange things happen like this
in in the ancient world this is 336 bce
and this is the famous wedding where
philip ii is assassinated by his
bodyguard who was likely philip ii's
former lover but once philip ii gets
assassinated you could imagine that many
people are wanting to have a go at the
throne in particular alexander aided by
his mother olympias
and so
immediately there tends there starts to
be a consolidation of power and the
first way to consolidate power is to
kill off all of the folks who might
threaten you
and so olympias and alexander and many
historians give credit mainly to olympia
some say alexander was involved more or
less but they go on a killing spree
europa is killed cairneus is killed
these are the children of cleopatra
eurydice at the time of this we're
talking 336 335 bce these would have
been they would have been toddlers they
would have been two at most three years
old they are being killed there are some
accounts that cleopatra is killed or she
is forced to hang herself there are some
accounts that some combination of them
are burned alive alexander goes after
atlas the famous uncle who insulted him
at the wedding party only a few years
ago he kills his cousin a mantis who
might have had a claim to the throne
other princes so this is this bloody
bloody period so even though sometimes
people glorify some of these rulers like
alexander the great that how they
unified all these people and they
pushed culture throughout the world or
however you want to talk about it they
came to they they usually come to power
in very brutal ways and they're
conquering is also very brutal no you
really we really shouldn't romanticize
oh let's conquer other people a war is
ugly and when when there's multiple
factions coming to a throne that is also
ugly so we are shortly after philip ii's
death alexander with the help of his
mother is able to consolidate power
within his family really secure his
place as the king of the macedonian or
the macedonian empire and so the next
thing is is to secure his hold on the
empire militarily and you immediately
start having rebellions to the north and
west
of
macedon or macedon
and so in particular the illyrians which
is in modern day albania so this region
right over here they start to revolt
alexander goes and makes a point of
sieging sieging the pass at pellium this
is a very strategic location but while
he's there with his military forces so
while he's there with his military
forces you can imagine the other city
states of greece in particular athens
and thebes say hey now's our chance the
king king philip is dead alexander's out
fighting with the illyrians let's rise
up and regain our independence and many
of them thought that alexander might
have already died in a previous military
campaign
and so you can imagine they were very
surprised after alexander
took control through a siege at pellium
and is able to come down surprisingly
quickly he really makes his soldiers
march hundreds of kilometers in a matter
of weeks to come down
to come down and
put down the rebellion
from his point of view at thebes and the
thebans refuse to
stop rebelling and so in retaliation
alexander the great completely destroys
thebes this famous this famous city of
antiquity this you know only a few
decades before this time the leading
city-state in all of greece and so he
destroys thebes he enslaves its people
but that's what allows him to
essentially scare the rest of the
city-states of greece to come in line he
hasn't conquered sparta or his empire
hasn't conquered sparta that'll happen
soon
but the rest but it really consolidates
his power and now we're talking 335 bce
he's ready to think about doing what his
father was planning and going off and
trying to conquer asia